lady pépettes sortir disco texte de
christine oman villemin illustrations de
stéphane sénégas
kaléidoscope c'est l'histoire d'une
sorcière méchant très très méchante et
affreuse vraiment affreuse évidemment
une seule chose intéresse manger des
enfants
mais comme elle est moche terriblement
moche les enfants se sauvent dès qu'il
la voit et elle n'en attrape jamais elle
a bien essayé d'en piégé deux en les
attirant dans sa maison en pain d'épicés
mais ce n'était pas une très bonne idée
les deux garnements l'ont enfermé dans
le faux et lui ont volé ses économies
elle décide alors de se rendre au
congrès des sorcières qui est l'endroit
rêvé pour connaître les dernières
nouveautés en matière de pièges à
enfants que deviens tu lui demandes la
fée carabosse ça marche les affaires oh
la la dur dur ça fait une éternité que
je n'ai pas attrapé d'enfants à les
temps changent interviennent la vieille
postulat les bonbons sont dépassés les
enfants d'aujourd'hui veulent des
paillettes du spectacle pour les attirer
il leur faut de l'exceptionnel du
essentielle national du show business du
grandiose bref il faut les épater les
sidéré les scotcher la sorcière prend
des notes et s'en retourne chez elle
avec un plan d'enfer grand un relooking
grand deux cours de chant grand troyes
cours de danse à l'institut de beauté
l'esthéticienne se désole oh là là il ya
du travail ma ptite dame depuis combien
de temps n'avez vous pas fait de masques
hydratants votre peau et toute sèche et
ses grands poids sur le menton toute la
semaine la sorcière se fait pas tout y
est chouchouté pomponner c'est dur mais
à la fin le résultat lui plaît au
conservatoire de la chanson la
professeure en a les oreilles et canche
et aux youyous ya du boulot reprenez
auclair 2 l'une pour voir or aux homos
n'ont arrêté toute la semaine notre
sorcière fait des mamies maumus des do
ré mi fa sol c'est dur mais à la fin le
résultat lui plaît à l'école de danse la
professeure en reste les bras ballants
et ben c'est pas gagné tourner un peu
pour voir les bras comme ça bon on
repart de zéro savez-vous sont vos pieds
toute la semaine la sorcière fait du hip
hop des claquettes du flamenco et des
petits sauts et arrêter les cacahuètes
ordonne la danseuse vous avez de trop
grosses fesses la sorcière est épuisé
mais à la fin le résultat lui pelé de
retour chez elle la sorcière se dit
qu'il lui faut un nom de scène quelque
chose qui sonne bien facile à retenir
suzie dolly laurine zaz est lady lady
pépettes oui ça c'est un an toute
contente de sa trouvaille elle s'enferme
dans son salon et met au point un numéro
qu'elle répète sans relâche jusqu'à ce
qu'il soit parfait puis elle s'inscrit à
une émission de télévision
le grand jour arrive lorsque vient son
tour de monter sur la scène elle se
présente bonsoir chers public je
m'appelle lady pépette et je suis
danseuse chanteuse ma chanson danse et
s'intitule vient dans ma maison tu
verras mon chaudron attention ça va
décoiffer alors elle se lance sur la
piste ça swingue ça rox a claqué chauffe
la salle vraiment quel style qu'elle
voit le succès est immédiat tout le
monde veut limiter les filles se coiffe
comme lé garçon cif sa chanson on lui
demande des autographes des photos
dédicacées des interviews un matin on
sonne à sa porte une petite fille toutes
deux dû et poteaux l'est pas comme cette
grande en bus de gretel une vraie
maigrichonne celle-là au lady je t'adore
je suis depuis le début de ta carrière
youpi se dit la sorcière mon plan marche
et j'ai réussi elle jubile enfin elle a
réussi à tirer un enfant je connais
toutes les figures parker continue la
fille regarde un pas en avant de me tour
lady s'approche doucement s lèchent déjà
les babines claque des mains poursuit la
gamine les doigts crochus aux ongles
vernis se tendent vers la mignonne
petit mouvement du bassin pirouette à
gauche mais non à droite la pirouette
sentant conseiller les 10 vous êtes sûr
c'est quand même moi qui les ai
inventées cette chorégraphie et après
demande la petite fille après petit pas
tourner la tête une deux claque des
doigts non pas comme ça comme ça ah oui
j'ai compris tiens ce deal est dit et si
j'en faisais une danseuse elle pourrait
être derrière moi ça ferait pas mal dans
mon spectacle bon tiens oui d'accord
bonne idée mais le prochain enfin je le
mange le lendemain on sonne à la porte
un petit garçon tout mignon et très
appétissant pas comme cette grande
asperge de celle qui sentait le chou
l'édile est dit s'écrit l'enfant
hystérique prends moi dans ton show
regarde jeu dans un hyper bien
annonce se dilatant ce tiers celui là je
le boulotte mais le gamin s'est déjà
lancé dans une démonstration ahurissante
après tout il serait pas mal dans mon
numéro se dit lady bon mais le prochain
juré craché je le mange
le lendemain ding dong une classe de ce1
tout entière envahi le perron quel
festin se réjouit les 10 je vais même
pouvoir en surgelé au lady on adore ce
que tu fais dit le délégué de classe on
est venu pour apprendre les pas lady
réfléchi quelques instants et une idée
lumineuse surgi dans son esprit et si je
montais une comédie musicale s intitulé
lady pépette et les pépites the show il
y aurait des effets spéciaux des
danseurs sur 100 g en défigurant volant
lady pépettes rêve la troupe irait en
tournée à las vegas puis dans le monde
entier il y aurait des vêtements lady
pépettes des sacs les types et pète oui
c'est ça je suis génial réflexion faite
ce n'est pas tellement intéressant de
croquer les enfants c'est gras et sucrés
et je n'ai pas intérêt à prendre du
poids si je veux faire du cinéma